[inaudible] joining me today is an author,
a speaker,
and the president of the Reagan Legacy Foundation.
Mike,
Greg,
and welcome to the Rubin report.
Hey,
good to be with you.
Thanks for having me.
I am glad to have you here.
You come from a famous family.
Is that fair to say?
They tell me,
you know what,
I tell people and love you.
They say famous family,
but they don't understand how absolutely famous to this.
There's only,
there's only two people ever born and or raised in a family that the mother
would go on to become an academy award winning actress,
and the father would go on to become president of the United States.
And that's my sister,
Maureen passed away in 2001 and myself.
No one else has lived that life.
And so that makes it more understandable to me why people always say,
so tell me about your family.
Yeah.
You know,
no matter what I've done in life would tell me about your family.
Well,
it's truly a,
I don't even know if bizarre is the word,
but it seemingly is a bizarre level of fame because there's a political element
and the Hollywood element,
and you combine those two things,
and especially the way these days where politics and Hollywood have become the
same thing.
It's,
it's a unique place.
It is a unique place.
I like to tell people about my mom,
Jane Wyman,
you know,
I say,
but my mother has two stars on the Hollywood walk of fame.
My Dad only has one,
and my mother also has her hand prints and footprints are Grumman's.
Chinese dad does not.
Wow.
So in Hollywood,
she won the game politics.
He did.
Yeah.
All right,
so let's,
let's do a little,
we're going to spend the first half doing a little bio and talking about your
dad and your mom and the family and all that.
So just tell me a little bit about just growing up.
You've grow.
Yeah.
Well,
you know it growing up it shit because people think,
hey,
you're so lucky.
I used to get that school.
You're so lucky.
Your parents are rich or famous and you go,
yeah,
but I'm boarding at school at six years old and that's what a lot of people
don't understand.
That era of Hollywood children,
that's what we all grew up mad at.
Our parents,
because we're boarding school,
six years old,
I'm at Chad Reese school,
Rancho Ponte,
pals,
Verdi's.
My sister's four years older than me.
She's there also and people are saying how lucky you are as you're crying
yourself to sleep every night.
And so we did.
We grew up angry because we're very jealous of the parents or the children who
got dropped off by their moms and dads every single day at school and then got
picked up and we didn't get picked up.
And so we grew up a little,
a little angst,
if you will.
Some of us wrote books about those those days and that era as well that,
what were your folks doing at that time?
Well,
my mom,
my mom was an actress.
She just won an academy award in 1948 best actress back in 48 my dad was,
you know,
doing Hollywood.
He was president of screen actors guild dealing with all those issues.
They got divorced and in 1948 so I was living with my mom at that time in,
in Beverly Hills.
I say to my mom,
mom,
I want to be in your business.
And she would say,
no,
it's,
if you don't want to be in this business is really tough.
You know,
it's a tough grind.
You never know if you're going to make it.
And I'm thinking to myself,
I'm living in a mansion in Beverly Hills.
We've got a maid,
we got to cook.
I've got a Cadillac,
two stories.
I said,
I kind of liked this industry.
Maybe you just don't want the competition from a child.
And,
and so that's,
that's what I grew up.
But you know something,
it was really,
it was really a great life in so many levels because my parents never forgot
where they were from.
My mom was from Saint Joe,
Missouri.
My Dad from Tampico,
Illinois.
And they brought those values with them when they came to California.
So Maureen and I,
even though not liking boarding at school and being angry at times and missing
our parents terribly,
uh,
really got grounded well with both my mom and my dad because my dad even
divorced from my mother.
Never forgot he had another family even after he married Nancy.
So when did your dad get involved in politics?
When was that shit?
Well,
use was when he became president of screen actors guild.
Very,
very to golf with that.
Yeah.
And it's like,
what year is that?
That's around 19,
1950s.
Late forties to 50s or what have you.
Yeah,
well a lot of people don't know.
We got involved more and more in politics because of things kept on happening to
him.
You know,
he uh,
uh,
was the king of the bees.
My mom was the king of the A's,
if you will,
at the time.
Uh,
so his career wasn't going really well.
It wasn't magic,
if you will.
He had to go to Las Vegas to do a stand up act at a hotel in Vegas to make
money.
They have to have the family be able to eat.
There's no video of that because their Pasta,
oh,
there probably is video somewhere on that.
Credible.
But again,
you know,
back then the parents didn't share what their children to tough times.
Now parents tell everything to their children.
Uh,
which is crazy.
That's a whole other show.
But it really is.
But you know,
we never knew until later on that tough things dad was going through.
Ended up getting a show,
General Electric Theater,
if you will.
Out of that,
he's doing GE theater and going around the country and speaking to General
Electric Plants.
Bobby candy picks up the phone,
calls the president of General Electric and says,
we have a problem.
The President of Ge is,
why is the attorney general calling me?
And the problem is this,
Ronald Reagan's going around the country speaking not well of his brother John
Candy at these plants about government.
And Bobby Kennedy says to him,
basically,
you know,
your,
your government contracts are coming up for renewal.
And if you could find a way to get rid of that guy,
you could probably get your government contracts renewed within 72 hours.
My father,
a Democrat at the time.
Yeah.
General Electric Theater is canceled.
Ronald Reagan doesn't have a job.
So what does he do?
Changes to Republican.
Yeah.
So that was the moment that was the moment changes to a Republican and then he
has time to sit down cause he not giving the speeches anymore and he combines
all the speeches he's been giving and he ends up with a brand new speech.
You might've heard of it,
a time for choosing and gives it for Barry Goldwater in 1964 and the rest is
history.
Bobby Kennedy does not make that phone call.
My Dad's not doing anything for Goldwater because he's too busy hosting one of
the top 10 television shows on Sunday night on TV.
It's such an incredible story because in an odd way,
he was almost forced into the real part of his political career.
Yeah.
He never,
he never thought he was gonna run for governor or president.
I'd states whatever.
He needed a job.
Yeah.
And he was forced out of the job and you had the job and was made very angry by
Bobby Kennedy and it forced him to go to the other other side,
if you will.
And really,
as I said,
the rest of his pick your folks talk politics at all.
Oh No.
I called my mom one time after my dad gave one of those great speeches he gave.
I said,
Monte,
just here,
dad's speech last night.
She says,
no,
I heard it in 1938 didn't like it.
They don't think much of it now.
But interestingly enough,
you know that I found after she passed going through were things she'd written
letters to my dad.
She'd sent money to his campaigns for governor,
for President United States.
Returned letters from my father to my mom.
Never knew,
cause she never really talked politics at all during your years in television.
She's stayed completely away from it.
And she never say anything about my dad when he was president until the day we
buried him.
And then she said some very nice kind things.
What year did your folks get divorced?
1948 they were married.
1940 divorced in 1948 men on a set of a movie.
So,
all right,
so let's flash forward a little bit to now your dad.
Now it's,
you know,
late seventies,
and now he's sort of the it guy.
What was that like different,
you know,
we had my dad got an anything in that 20 year.
Oh yeah.
Here you're never,
you're never ready for a man or anybody in your home to become president United
States of America because secret service comes into your house.
Uh,
I went all over the country in 19 eight,
well 76 and 80,
I think the last month of 1980,
66 airplane rides,
19 states.
My sister Maureen was doing this very same thing and you know,
he gets elected in three days later.
I've got secret service in my life.
Uh,
and our son gets secret service at that time.
He was like too,
they ended up going to school with him.
Uh,
it really changes your life completely.
anonymity,
don't have a,
you can't really go anywhere.
You got to tell somebody you're going there and have the secret service follow
you wherever you go.
It's not the easiest life in the world.
If you're gonna imagine a three year old going to preschool with secret service
protection,
um,
or my wife Colleen,
when she gave birth to our daughter Ashley,
we found out her code name,
which was,
you know,
raindrop before we knew she was a girl.
Huh?
I mean,
the first thing my wife heard as ash,
who was being born was,
we have an arrival.
Raindrop has arrived.
We have an arrival.
And my wife looked at me,
she said,
is there anything private about my life anymore?
I said,
no,
not really.
Yeah,
boy,
that's where children stop with two because that's never gonna happen again.
But we found out her code name before we found out she was a girl.
How did that wear on you guys?
Once that level of fame and that level of intrusiveness,
if,
if you can,
if you can keep a marriage together for eight years with secret service
protection,
your marriage will last forever.
And we just had our 43rd wedding anniversary.
We celebrated our 45th year of our first date last December 7th.
It's very,
very tough because secret service has given to blood relatives downward,
not given the spouses.
So clean didn't have secret service.
We did.
Huh.
And,
and it's very different,
you know,
clean had these visions of driving on the freeway,
family accident,
all thrown from the car,
secret service.
Pick up Cameron,
Ashley and may put us in an ambulance,
take us to the hospital through a clean and cell phone and say,
call someone.
I think that is the vision you're at.
Right.
Because she got,
she doesn't have that protection.
So not easy at all.
Uh,
being married,
you know,
in that situation.
But we muddled through,
I got a great wife from Nebraska,
very strong.
She looks at me as a stock of corn.
She planted me and she just keeps on taking care of me all these years.
What,
what was your relationship with your dad like as he was first running for
president?
I wrote a book called lesson my father taught me about all those years going out
to the ranch when I was a child,
learned about America,
heard every,
every song of every military operation known to mankind.
He was a true patriot and that's why I learned about the tax laws in America.
That's where I learned about American and the greatness of America and,
and riding out to the ranch with them and riding horses and shooting ground
squirrels and going swimming and cutting firewood.
I bought him his first chainsaw.
When you become president,
that all goes away because now he's got John Barletta secret service who just
passed away a few months ago,
you know,
riding with my dad and,
and it just completely changed.
You don't have those close moments that in fact you had previous so migrated
years.
My Dad was prior to the election and the great years after he out of office,
we got to spend time together and,
and when he had,
you know,
that terrible,
terrible disease that he had so many people had Alzheimer's,
we probably build the best relationship for a ship of our lives because in 1992
I made a decision and the decision was the next time I see my dad,
I'm going to hug him and tell him I love him.
And I did that in 1992 and he hugged me back and said,
I love you too.
And from that point on,
every time we would see each other,
we would hug each other and say,
I love you.
When he got ahold timers and he got to a point he could no longer say my name,
he remembered I was the young man who hugged him alone and hugged him goodbye.
And so when he saw me,
he would open up his arms,
not able to say my name and I'd fall into his arms and he gave me that little
hug and I'd hug him.
And one day we're up visiting Nancy at the house because you no longer visit
with dad and we'd be there.
And uh,
I got up to leave and got to the car and Coleen says to me,
you forgot days or whatever,
forget,
look at the door.
I looked back at the front door of the House and dad had remembered that I had
forgotten to hug him goodbye.
Wow.
And he had gotten up and Nancy had helped him a little baby steps all the way to
the front door and he was standing in the front door like this.
I had forgotten to hug him goodbye.
And I said,
oh my God.
And ran pool tear up thinking about and hugged him and he hugged me back and he
turned,
took the baby steps back into the house.
But just one of those wonderful moments I just had with my dad after he was out
of the White House.
Yeah.
Was there,
was it tough for you,
the,
the way people would talk about your dad and Nancy obviously,
that she wasn't,
she wasn't your mom,
that,
that relationship was the one that everyone focused on what,
and it was a relationship that was in the house saying the relationship you saw
is what patty,
Ron and I am marine lived.
Yeah.
It was about them.
You couldn't get them apart with a crow bar.
Um,
and,
and that's just the way it was.
I write,
I write in my book about the fact that Dad,
when my mom divorced him,
uh,
he will tell you,
or you would have told you it was the worst day of his life.
He thought,
I'm never going to let this happen to me again.
Nancy's dad walked out on her and her mother the day she was born,
walked out.
Wow.
Gone.
Goodbye.
Didn't want a kid.
I'm Outta here.
She swore when she grew up,
I'm never going to have another man walk out on me.
These two Meta Chasen's for dinner,
get together and these two people,
you could not get them apart with a crowbar.
And so even as kids had a fight our way into the system to get our time,
you know,
with dad,
uh,
especially,
and that's just the way it was.
I think it was depicted pretty well on the funeral for Nancy Dad and so on.
That's just the way it was with Nancy.
She was kind of the gatekeeper,
if you will,
getting to our father and the place you could really spend time with him is get
them to the ranch.
You can be with them at the ranch.
You got a lot of great times.
Was He happiest there?
I mean,
when he could get away from the political craziness.
Love the ranch.
Yeah.
Uh,
you know,
young America's foundation who bought it a few years ago.
I do a lot of things with them.
Uh,
they bring high school kids up there and college kids up there and I speak to
them.
He really referred to it as his cathedral and it really was his cathedral.
It's where he could go up and really relaxed that cutting wood.
He did all that stuff.
When you go and see the ranch,
he's the one that really built the fences and did all of it.
So when you see all those pictures of mean it's real as opposed to now where
everything is so staged,
every time politician shows up anywhere in a hat with this,
they're holding the pitchfork or just any,
anything that now it's so,
oh yeah.
He was a lot of firsts.
I mean that very true about immuno,
he was the first president to show up on d day at normally.
Yeah.
He was the first president to salute getting on and off Air Force One or marine
one.
You know,
he put a lot of firsts that are after that now have been followed by others.
Yeah.
Talk to me a little bit about those first couple of years of the presidency.
And it was definitely not all easy.
No,
it wasn't easy.
And,
uh,
but you know the interesting enough when I was campaigning for him in 1980,
call them on the phone from Iowa and he,
uh,
and he talking to me and I said,
dad,
you know,
you're going to get beat by George h w Bush here in Iowa.
Could you I just got off the phone,
the campaign staff and they said,
we're doing fine.
It's one of,
they're lying to you.
I said,
I've been all over this state now for the last three weeks doing coffees.
I've them 20 doughnuts by eight o'clock in the morning,
87 cups of coffee.
That's commitment and uh,
doing all these things.
I said,
I'm telling you,
you're going to get beat because you're not here.
This is your state.
You're the favorite son of the state who is doing an event Saturday.
You're not even going to be at it cause you're staffed than think you need to be
there.
They're running you as if you're better than the people in Iowa and he's going
to beat you.
And he gave me a typical father.
Thank you Michael.
I appreciate the call.
Thank you for helping out in Iowa,
but my staff says I'm good.
Who Wins?
Iowa Hw Bush.
Yeah.
Couple of weeks later in New Hampshire,
I get a call at six 30 in the morning at the house.
He says,
I have a press release for you.
I said,
why are you calling me?
Is that press release?
I need your approval on or disapproval.
It's up to you,
so why are you calling me?
He said,
let me read you the press release and you knew,
tell me whether I should give it to the media or not.
It's your call is to press release firing Roger Stone.
Paul Manafort,
John Sears and Charlie Black,
and he calls me and and I said the news.
That's right,
and I said,
done,
do it.
He says,
fine.
You'll be hearing about in your seven o'clock news hour,
I'm going to get off the phone with you and give it to the media.
And then I thought to myself,
what happens if he loses the day?
They're going to blame me.
I sit up.
My Dad said,
you're going to win today.
He says,
yeah,
we're going to win today.
So go ahead,
go ahead and do it.
He says,
give my love to Coleen and,
and Cameron,
at the time we didn't have Ashley,
I said Goodbye Dad.
So,
you know,
the,
these are the things he would do when he was president because he knew the
dynamics to allow me the opportunity to fire these guys was amazing.
So when you hear these guys names down Manafort and stone and some of the others
that they're so in the news lately,
votes stuff,
what does that ring to you?
I've known they meant evil for years.
I mean,
I,
it's amaze me,
the Republican party and keeps on going back to the same,
well over all these years.
I mean,
Charlie's okay.
But I mean stone and in,
in,
in Manaford have always been like this.
I mean,
it just,
the truth and I,
I tweeted,
I remember during the campaign with Trump,
I said,
you know,
Ronald Reagan with Manafort and stone,
never one without them,
never lost.
And I said,
I suggest you know,
to Trump,
you want to see the same dynamic.
I would get rid of both of them and it really turned it around because he was
doing very badly when they got rid of them.
He never lost again.
What year was these fascinations of those 19 and March 31 1981 81 actually,
I think that is my first real memory of anything.
You know,
visually I was five years old at the time,
not even five.
It's about four and a half years ago.
And I remember my folks watching that and I'd,
I remember seeing on the news,
you know,
they had like a,
an image,
a cart,
you know,
like that richer character of his body.
And I,
I vividly remember that at that age.
What was that like for you guys?
You know,
I was in my office secret service.
I was in business,
meaning my office and secret service agent came in.
So there's been an assassination attempt back in Washington and everything's
okay.
It was Mike Ludy and who my agent George,
my detail that day and he's been,
everything's okay.
Close the door,
and I went,
people looked at me like that was cold,
that was cold.
So I picked up the phone,
called the White House,
asked for Nancy.
Nancy was at the White House.
I walked out and said,
Mike,
my dad's been shot.
He says,
no,
he's fine.
I said,
no,
Nancy,
not at the White House.
There's only one reason she wouldn't be at the White House.
And the car was on the way to the White House.
If she's not there,
she's someplace else.
And I would say that would be the hospital.
And Mike said,
no.
They say he's fine.
I said,
check it.
Five minutes later,
Mike says,
you're right.
He was shot.
So now we go home and of course the press to surrounded our house,
we're being held captive basically in the home.
And they finally sent a plane out from Washington to pick us up.
Uh,
but we're asked to stay home.
They didn't was to rush to Washington for fear of the markets would crash.
People would think it was worse than it really was.
But it really was worse than people thought it was because he was very close to
depth.
If Jerry Parr was the Asian charge that day,
if Jerry,
if dad and not coughed up oxygenated blood,
uh,
they would have gone to the White House.
He would have bled to death internally.
But he did right at the right time and they went to the hospital and I tell the
story when they get the hospital,
they cut the suit off.
My Dad,
you now see you at the library.
And I remember the next day when we able to see that we finally got in very late
at night,
saw dad 10 o'clock the next morning.
And the humor that he shared with the country,
it's the same humory always shared with the family.
He always had a joke.
He always had a sense of humor,
helps.
What was great about debt in,
unless you were rushing his life was great.
Yeah,
we'll get to that.
And,
and I,
so I walk in,
I walk in 10 o'clock with my family and my dad looks at me.
She's,
you know,
uh,
yesterday I was shot.
I said,
dad,
the world knows you were shot yesterday.
He says,
well,
if you're ever gonna get shot,
don't be wearing a new suit.
I said,
what?
He says,
when I was shot yesterday,
I had a brand new suit and I had just picked it up the day before.
He says,
I can't.
I walked into the hospital and they put me on this Gurney and the cut that suit
off of my body and the last time I saw I was in shreds in the corner of the
hospital room.
That's why I tell you Michael,
but everybody gets shot.
Don't be wearing a new suit.
I said,
fine,
I won't wear a new suit.
I'll talk to lead to put something else on me.
And he says,
that young man who shot me,
I said,
yeah,
John Hinckley.
Yes,
it was John Hinckley.
I said,
what?
He says hydro stand his parents from in the oil business?
Yes.
Understand they live in Denver?
Yeah.
Do you think they have any money now?
He understand he was on the table close to death six hours before I'm in the
room.
Put that in perspective.
And I said,
well,
they live in Denver.
They're in the oil business.
Dan,
I'm sure they have money.
He says,
do you think they'd ever buy me a new suit?
That's what he says to me.
And I just looked at him,
I said,
ask,
I don't know,
but that's what he says to me six hours after off the table.
How did that experience change him?
You know how a change was,
and people have written books,
they really need to call family members.
So many people write books,
don't they think they know everything.
But you know,
family members have the inside baseball stories.
You don't want to go there.
And so it's been upsetting.
Some of the things been said,
how it changed and was that he believed he was truly saved for a reason.
Can we became closer really to God,
if you will.
Uh,
and that,
and that's where he was.
And,
and,
and a lot of people just misunderstood that.
The,
you know,
wasn't the same guy,
he wasn't the same guy,
but he didn't put a gym in the second floor of the White House.
But two and a half inches on his chest,
you know,
and got stronger because of the,
the bullet in the wound and what have you.
But he just became more,
he came,
became closer to God and felt that there was a reason he was there.
And you know,
some,
he ended up being right.
So did that then galvanize a lot of the things that he ended up doing in the
second term and everything that happened with Russia had Mr Gorbachev tear down
this wall and everything else.
Yeah.
Because if you look,
I mean you got to stay on my dad.
It's March 31st three months later.
Who Shot Pope John Paul.
Oh yeah.
And he lives.
So what is the first thing my father does?
I tell people that just want to go out and speak.
How many people you speak to,
if you asked the question,
how many can recite the Lord's prayer?
How many people raised their hand?
I'm ready.
You know
how many people go live the Lord's prayer?
Cause my dad before he went back to the White House for gave John Hinckley for
trying to kill him.
Pope John Paul before he went back to his paypal duties for,
gave the young man who tried to kill him two months later,
three months later,
both of them meet in Rome at the Vatican,
one of they now have in common to really talk about both believing they've been
saved for a higher purpose.
And the higher purpose becomes what freedom to Poland and the Berlin walls when
we coming down.
So that he always had that message of freedom in it.
I mean that,
that,
that idea of the individual and freedom and you know,
so the line,
and you touched on this earlier,
but the line of I didn't leave the Democratic Party,
the Democratic Party left me.
That's become very,
to me that's like,
that's it.
Because I was a big lefty most of my life and even just in the last five years
I've sort of woken up to them to what they've become.
I know that's probably funny to you and if you're not,
but you know,
dad was sitting here,
he'd say [inaudible] sister Maria was the first Republican in the family.
Yeah.
She's the one that really,
you know,
pushed him and pushed him and pushed him to,
to do all this.
So,
so when he said that was,
was he really saying,
well that was,
was the effect of what he was saying.
I get,
I get what happened with GM was just that,
that when they left me,
meaning that they want government to solve everything and that's just not what I
want.
Yeah.
And that's not the way they used to be.
But if you go back and take you back historically,
yeah.
Back then a,
uh,
a Liberal Democrat was a conservative.
Yeah.
Today of course.
Would it be a conservative,
I mean,
the reality is John Kennedy would be like,
today would be a conservative.
Yeah.
And the fact is that today Reagan may be a liberal.
I mean not where they are,
but people are going to miss quote.
Yeah.
I realized that,
no,
I can go back and say,
you know,
as governor,
he raised taxes,
signed abortion bill and what have you,
and instead things later on in his life.
But now with all the social meaning all of the things out there,
you know,
people remember what you did,
at birth and they holding against you in the public opinion in that court,
which is tough,
uh,
to do so.
It's a,
it's a tough world out there anymore.
And Elo for all the regular who gave amnesty in 1986 which Stan,
you know,
there's people who wouldn't support him today.
Yeah.
What do you think he would make of just generally the way politics is now in
terms of it's the,
that seemingly won't talk to each other.
We're in the,
we're in what week six of the shutdown.
Um,
just the whole tenor of everything.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's not something that he would wrap his arms around.
You remember when he was elected?
Uh,
W we don't have any statesman anymore.
We used to have states,
both sides.
Yeah.
You know,
Hubert Humphrey,
you,
let's go through the list of people you disagreed with,
maybe politically,
but they were a great statesman.
You know you great debate.
At the end of the debate,
we all had dinner together type thing.
You know,
back in the day we got the largest tax break in American history,
but how do we get that?
Tip O'Neill was the head of the house.
He was speaker house.
Here's the guy who would disagree with my father on everything known to mankind.
Yeah.
Boy,
his dad do invites him to the White House for dinner with his wife.
He goes up there for dinner a couple of days later when he's back in his office,
tells the staff,
I'm going to carry the legislation on the tax cut staff looks at him and said,
you're nuts.
There's boll weevils.
They used to be boll weevil before they can.
Blue Dog Democrats by the way,
give me some period pieces,
but there's enough bull wheels on the,
on the house floor.
They will pass through.
You put it on the floor.
What did the president of promise you?
What did he say was going to give you to put it on the floor?
Nothing.
Then what did you talk about?
We never talked about taxes all night long.
Then what did you talk about with the president?
Greatness of America,
the goodness of her people and how the two of us working together and make it
better for all Americans.
Before I knew it,
we're telling iris stories,
we're having a glass of wine today.
I'm telling I'm going to carry the legislation.
You can't do that today.
So do you think that was his greatest skill beyond political maneuvering per se?
Although I guess that is political maneuvering at its,
at its core,
yeah.
Here will,
you also said to him as an aside,
he says,
and by the way,
I promised not to campaign against any Democrats who supported in the next
election,
which helped a lot.
Yeah.
That's cause he had a lot going for him.
But he used the same thing,
work with Gorbachev,
you know,
same thing,
work with,
with all of them.
He just,
you know,
Ronald Reagan for best friend as Jimmy Stewart said,
Ronald Reagan for best friend,
he was that kind of a guy,
easy to get along with.
But he knew what he wanted and he knew the best way to go about getting it.
And He,
and he did it.
What was it like watching the media go after your dad,
either,
either justly or unjustly,
that could not have been fun?
Well,
yeah,
it's something,
you know,
it gets maddening.
I remember Maureen,
I,
when he,
when he was campaigning in New Hampshire,
he paid for the microphone and Maureen and I looked at each other when it's
about time,
he got mad.
God never gets mad.
He finally got mad and we thought that was,
that was a change of tune.
Excuse me.
And,
uh,
in New Hampshire,
but it's tough watching people attack anybody in your family.
Um,
it didn't bother.
Dad did nothing to bother him at all.
That Nancy would eat bananas at night.
She wouldn't sleep.
She toss and turn.
She call everybody known to mankind to see how do we stop this?
How do we stop it?
But Dad was just nonplus pie.
He didn't let it bother him.
He wasn't thin skinned.
Yeah.
I want to,
I mean,
some of that has to maybe some of the acting career.
And he was,
he was at a level of fame that was so absurd that he had,
he had lived through the struggle years and no,
you have to have the tough years too much where they came after him.
I mean,
he had the tough years.
It wasn't an easy life.
He,
but he never let anything stop him from really moving the ball forward and,
and,
and getting things done.
And I think that's important.
A lot of people today,
you know,
if they get stopped here,
they stopped.
They don't do anything else,
you know,
instead of fighting,
what next,
what door opened up now that I can go into and,
and maybe make a career out of it,
if you will.
Um,
and I think those lessons that can be taught to a lot of people today that,
you know,
everything's a work in progress.
Amir,
a ups guy the other day was at my house delivering something.
And,
and,
uh,
and said kind of a snide remark,
Nice House as,
as he was leaving and I said,
yeah,
I took me 50 years to get here.
It didn't cut.
It wasn't born here.
I took me 50 years to get this house.
A lot of people don't know about,
you know,
if you want something,
you gotta work for it.
Nobody's going to hand it to you.
My mother taught me that,
you know,
back when I was 10 years old,
I want a 10 speed bike.
All my other friends were getting 10 speaks bikes given to them by their parents
for free.
I went down to hand sort Sacary Santa Monica picked out a blue 10 speed Schwinn
bike,
went home and said to my mom,
mom,
you buy me this.
I'm going to love you forever.
No kids ever done that with his parents.
My mom said,
well,
how badly do you want it?
I said,
mom,
well,
I'm more than anything good.
Do you want it enough to get a job?
I said,
what job?
I'm 10 years old.
She to deliver papers.
What?
So she opens up the paper looking for ads.
Ah,
you could sell papers in front of the Good Shepherd Church in Santa Monica where
we go to church on Sunday mornings.
It's available sign here.
I signed a contract with my mother when I was 10 years old.
She loaned me the money to buy that bike and I would pay her back on Sunday
afternoon after church with some of the profits I made from selling by the 25
cents for a Sunday paper that was this thick.
But what I made,
what I made I,
I give it back to her and I asked her,
I said,
why are you doing this to me?
All my friends are getting bikes given to them.
She says,
because I build men,
not boys.
If I give you what you want,
you'll be a 40 year old child.
But if I teach you now that you have to work for what you want in life,
you'd be a 40 year old man.
And that's what I built.
So you deserve that house.
Damn rights.
All right.
So let's just do a little bit more about your dad and then I want to spend the
rest of the time talking about what you're doing now with the foundation and
everything else.
So I think it's pretty fair to say that the,
that the fall of the Soviet Union was,
was his greatest accomplishment within,
I think you'd agree with that.
No,
y'all get the fuck.
I don't know.
You might pull in something here that I don't know what you're,
rather than bringing me into the family.
Yeah.
So other than the other [inaudible] coming in the family.
Was there anything when he,
when he left the presidency that he really felt was undone or that he had
really,
uh,
made an error on or anything like that?
Did he have any regrets?
No,
he had no regrets at all.
I think we'll be looking at his last speech that he gave,
really talked about the things that had been accomplished.
He was a great guy for using wean on I,
and he really understood it was a team effort,
um,
and [inaudible] very happy with what he was able to accomplish.
And being able to work with with others.
And,
and I said to Margaret Thatcher,
the day after the funeral,
she came to me,
we were having breakfast hotel and she said,
Oh,
Michael,
uh,
about your dad.
Just think of w w w what he,
we could have accomplished.
Who would've been elected in 1976?
I said,
Lady Thatcher,
if he'd been elected in [inaudible] 76,
the Berlin wall would still be up.
The Cold War would still be in place.
She said,
why do you say that?
I said,
where were you in 76?
Or was John Paul,
where was like,
Valencia work was Wako hovel where it was Mikhail Gorbachev.
They all need each other.
The fact of matter is he'd been elected then he would have been an out of office
even.
It was a two term president by the time of college,
Gorbachev came in.
The wall would still be up for some reason.
Faith,
you name it.
All the right people were in the right place at the right time.
And my dad was that leader able to work with each and every one of you.
Helmut Kohl,
you name it,
to bring everybody together.
Pope John Paul that ultimately brought down that Berlin Wall.
All of you are on the same page up until that point,
all of you are on other pages and if it's my dads that that one Cardi had on his
desk,
no telling you what you had accomplished and where you can go if you don't worry
who gets the credit.
Dad didn't worry about credit.
He worried about getting the job done.
He wanted to bring that wall down.
If you go back historically and look and listen to my father,
his speeches,
he was talking about that wall back when it was put up back in what,
1961 two o'clock in the morning.
August 13th I believe.
He talked about that wall from that point forward in his life.
And so that was,
that was a seminal thing for him and that wall coming down,
change the world.
So he obviously was an incredible communicator and the speeches and all that.
And obviously you had a way of reaching across the aisle.
Where there any people either that were us politicians or international fingers
that he just absolutely hated or felt that he could not work with?
Is there anyone know a way he didn't feel that way about anybody?
Um,
he,
he brought him all.
He really,
because there were people that hated him.
I mean,
we're all Yada,
but you know,
he look,
it was sitting behind us.
If you go to his funeral,
look who was sitting behind us at the,
at the church,
Mikhail Gorbachev,
you know,
he made friends of enemies.
You didn't make enemies of friends and he diffused so many things because of his
humor.
Being able to laugh at himself.
Last year or the year before on February six,
his birthday celebrated at the everywhere,
but the Reagan library,
it was a big event.
US Marines come up and what have you,
guest speaker last year,
Sam Donaldson.
That wouldn't happen today.
Yeah.
Not going to happen at all.
Even though they had this adversarial way.
They have mutual respect and,
and ultimately you have Sam Donaldson speaking,
you know,
on behalf of my father had his birthday last year at the library.
He made friends of people who were enemies and got things accomplished.
Whether it's Pope John Paul,
like the lengths of vocal hobby,
doesn't matter who it is,
Mikhail Gorbachev and turn turn him and Mikhail Gorbachev.
I worked with the Eureka College a few years ago.
We were able to get Mikhail Gorbachev,
go to Eureka College,
my dad's Alma Mater,
and speak to the Reagan Society at Eureka College about his relationship with my
dad wouldn't happen today.
And,
and that's what's,
that's what sad things.
See things deteriorate possibly when they were at such a great high level
relationship in all areas.
Yeah.
So you obviously mentioned your dad in the later years and obviously Alzheimer's
is,
there's no words to truly describe it in the story.
He told us incredible.
Do you remember the moment that you knew something was off because he must've
been this other worldly figure in a way even to you?
Do you remember seeing him one day and be out?
He was a,
he was gay,
he was losing a step,
if you will.
And they had an event celebrating his birthday,
um,
at the library or not the library,
what would become,
and they had the big event and a Lady Thatcher was a speaker and there had to be
a thousand people.
And under this tent is great.
And uh,
my dad introduced Lady Thatcher and uh,
to a great round of applause.
And when the bylaws was over,
he reintroduced her the exact same way he had just done and everybody got it and
everybody applauded again.
And that was the moment where I think the decision was probably made that a,
there's too many people in the room that sought that.
He had to say something.
And that's when the letter comes out in 19,
uh,
1994,
the letter comes in November 3rd,
I think 1994 when the letter comes out,
because too many people in the room saw that moment,
if you will.
But everybody you know,
who had just give a standing ovation to Lady Thatcher and my dad stood up and
gave another standing ovation to leave that your and my dad.
And,
and that,
that was the,
that was the moment where we knew that it was going to blossom from there to
national inquire.
And you didn't want national enquirer breaking the story.
You wanted the family to breaking the story in Dad.
Of course with the letter he wrote to the nation after the letter.
He didn't do any public appearances.
Diddy,
I,
I don't think he,
I don't think he did any after that.
Um,
I think the last one he gave was in that year,
but prior to the,
prior to the letter,
he might've given one a,
if you will.
Uh,
but it wasn't a,
it wasn't easy still.
I mean,
it wasn't just the early onset,
if you will,
of what he had.
I chaired the John Dug his French Alzheimer's foundation for four years.
I just left it,
this,
this last year.
And,
uh,
we just,
we're doing a whole program with Ucla and USC and,
uh,
colleges.
We took a university of San Francisco,
uh,
where were,
we took ethic,
we had 10,
$11 million in the bank and what we're doing is doing matching funds with these
universities and creating chairs.
So we turned the 11 to 22 million that is used strictly for research for
Alzheimer's.
There's a new program,
crisper that looked very promising in the future.
We're part of that.
Uh,
so you know,
people think maybe within five years something of Crispr does what everybody
thinks it might be able to do.
Uh,
it'd be great for,
for that,
for that issue.
All right,
so that's a pretty good segue.
What you're doing now and your dad's legacy,
you are the president of the Reagan Legacy Foundation.
Uh,
how do you keep a legacy like this live this,
this is not an easy thing to cut you off.
You know,
when my sister Maureen was dying of melanoma back in 2001,
I was with her in her hospital room.
This was about three months before she passed.
She was saint John's in Santa Monica,
chased everybody else out,
new state.
And we have that brothers sister conversation.
And she really worried about our dad's legacy.
And she asked,
he said,
Michael,
if it ever gets to a point you can walk away from radio,
would you?
I said,
why are you asking?
She says,
our father is a very important legacy and I would hope that you in fact would
help carry it for people.
Remember who he was,
who he is and who he was.
And I promised her then I would,
so 2009,
I chose to leave 26 years in radio,
uh,
walked away from radio I,
which is pretty tough because all of a sudden,
oh,
I've got to make a living too,
and I take no money from the foundation.
I said,
oh,
that's why I need to do,
create a foundation,
make money.
Media won't have fun with that one.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
Uh,
so out speaking premiere speakers bureau picked me up,
I thought speaking a lot,
30,
40,
50 speeches a year,
and we haven't started this foundation,
which originally was used to,
uh,
it still does,
to provide scholarships to men and women who serve aboard the USS Ronald Reagan,
which now is in Tokyo,
Japan,
keeping an eye on North Korea.
And so we provide scholarships to the young men and women who serve on the
Reagan,
but we do something different.
We also provide scholarships to their family members who are left back home.
Nobody else thinks about that.
They're serving as much as the one on the ship and they're trying to better
their lives education.
So we provide thousand dollars scholarships to those on the ship,
$2,000 scholarships to those left home.
And we do it every single year.
Um,
you know,
it,
but somewhere between 25 and $50,000 a year.
We,
whenever we can raise,
so we raised a million,
it'll be a million,
whatever it might be.
We do that.
Uh,
and,
and then I was in Germany a few years ago and I was at the Berlin Wall.
Ask them young man,
what do you know,
Berlin Wall?
He said,
well,
the Americans put it up to keep the communists out of their sector is,
excuse me.
I said,
boy,
we did a great job with our education system,
but there is no mention of Ronald Reagan,
nothing at the Brandenburg Gate,
nothing.
So I build a relationship with prowl Hildebrand,
her,
her and her husband who created the,
uh,
the malware museum,
which is the checkpoint Charlie Museum in Berlin.
And we funded through the Reagan legacy foundation around Reagan exhibit
overlooking Checkpoint Charlie there at that museum.
So you can learn about my father who got chain saw there,
all kinds of stuff.
The speech from the Brandenburg Gate is there and that's where we need to put
something in the ground,
the brand new brigade.
So I worked almost three years working with the red red government of Berlin.
And uh,
finally about two years ago,
three years ago,
they approved us putting a plaque in the ground.
So the,
the Adelai hotel,
which is back from the brand of brigade,
there's,
we have a huge
program there now are the thing that my dad,
uh,
commemorating the speech of black,
my dad commemorating his speech back in 1987.
June 12th.
So I did that.
Were Fun.
Right?
That's great.
Yeah.
Then I'm playing golf with a young man here in Los Angeles,
Beers later,
28 years old.
I said,
you know,
I'm leaving tomorrow for Paris and then I'm going out to a,
going out to Normandy on Saturday and Sunday.
I've been asked to raise the American flag at the American cemetery.
28 year old young man says to me,
why is there an American cemetery at Normandy?
I went,
oh my God.
Did you think d day is when your report card came home?
So I did that,
spent more time out there then and realized there was no mention of Ronald
Reagan,
their enormity,
especially at that great speech.
And so we now have partnered with the airborne museum at Saint Mary Glee's,
Saint Mary Glee's,
first time freed by American d day after all the paratroopers are going saving
private Ryan.
That's where they read it.
That's where the bridge is,
where it is the,
the 82nd airborne in the hundred and first there,
Waterloo if you will,
or their Gettysburg.
Um,
and we partner with them and we have now a Ronald Reagan center there.
Yeah.
Uh,
to,
to have,
uh,
conferences.
We've produced a film about that.
You go on my website,
Reagan Legacy foundation.org watched the film on that and say,
what else can we do?
And so last year we put together a program with the airborne museum to start
doing what we call a walkway to victory,
where you can,
you can buy a brick,
go online walkway to victory dot Tom Reagan legacy foundation dental work.
And you can purchase a brick $250 or 500 whatever you want to spend.
And we're putting the names of those who served in the European theatre and the
Second World War.
And if you don't know somebody,
you can donate to the foundation and we'll find that somebody,
so you're actually building it over time.
Oh Billy it over time in it.
It's coming.
And so it launched last June that lastly,
I think,
yeah,
just we put the first group in,
I think April or May,
we have about 300 bricks now.
We have another order in now to put more bricks in.
A lot of it's weather,
you can't do it because of weather or had enormously,
but people go online and do that.
And it's a great way to honor those who fought in the second world war in the
European theater.
And it really changed the world.
Absolutely changed it.
Part of what you guys are teaching about.
I mean there's,
there's incredible stories that would never happen now.
I mean about,
about actors.
So accurate,
some accurate and athletes that actually put their careers on hold.
Uh,
you know,
to fight in World War II,
which now to an athlete or an actor these days would sound,
sounded insane to Oh yeah.
And my dad couldn't go there,
uh,
because he was legally blind.
So he did over 300 films,
uh,
training films for those who didn't go there,
but have so many of these actors who,
who signed up and when are you have a,
there was a,
there was a TV show on Netflix,
I think it was the five.
The kids five came back during the famous directors of the time who came back,
but they were sent there and they're the ones who took the film of all those
encampments that we saw of the Jews.
That's how we found out about these things that were going on.
So we'll have special places put out for them.
Actors,
sports people who were involved,
who went there and gave up their careers,
if you will,
to go there.
Came back and we got the career's going,
if you will.
But it is,
it's such a great place.
Anybody who goes to normity needs to stop at Saint Marie Gleason.
People know that the,
the grave sites,
did you see at the American cemetery,
all of them were in that area of Saint Marie Gleason through there.
There,
Gosh,
thousand 15,000 grave sites that were there and the wife for the DDA,
mayor of Saint Mary Glee's called the mother of normity was the one who took
care of those grave sites all of those years making contact with the loved ones
that were left home.
And when they made the agreement,
the Americans with the French to have the American cemetery,
they gave the availability to the family members home to have their loved ones
sent back home or sent to the American cemetery.
That's where there's 9,600 the American cemetery and there are 15,000 sprint
spread throughout Saint Marie Gullies.
And,
and to go there and go the airborne museum and,
and,
and see the gliders and see how these,
these guys came in and what,
what was going on that day at Saint Marie Glee's is absolutely phenomenal.
And to be able to remember them with these bricks and what happens?
The 250 bucks.
Okay.
What happens with the money?
I'll tell you what happens.
The money we paid by the get the brick,
put it in the ground.
The profits are leftover,
which are pretty good,
are split between the airborne museum for their museum.
Yeah.
The upkeep and the Reagan Legacy Foundation,
which does what?
Provide scholarships to men and women in the board.
The USS Ronald Reagan.
Yeah.
So you got a real good guy.
Oh,
that's what it is.
Like as the lie that,
that,
and that's when we did to it because that was my father.
A lot of people don't know.
You go back and you'll listen to that speech point,
the hoc speech and think he was the first president.
Think about that.
It was 40th anniversary.
He was the first president of thought,
you know,
maybe I should show up on d day at Saint Mary Gleaves or at Normandy and give a
speech.
And He,
and he did.
Ah,
and,
and that his idea,
yeah.
It was his idea.
He,
you know,
my sister and I used to laugh about dad that uh,
uh,
if he didn't win the presidency of the United States and we tell them as a boy
scout,
we've taught him running for the presidency was like going for your eagle badge.
Yeah.
I mean that was my dad.
He was the Eagle Scout going for his eagle badge.
He never forgot about those who,
who gave their lives,
as I said,
300 training films,
uh,
that he did it.
He was legally blind.
He couldn't serve overseas wanting to be in the army was in the,
he was in the cavalry,
but to get in the army had a pass an I examined.
So what does he do?
He went out and he memorized the eye charts.
So when we went in to join the army and they put him in front of an eye chart,
cover your left eye or right eye read line three he hadn't memorized.
Wow.
And so d e F Pq,
you're in Reagan.
And then when they offered him the rank of major to stay in,
he said,
no,
the rank of major should be given only to someone who's able to serve overseas,
not someone who has to be able,
can only stay home.
So please give that major.
As someone who serves overseas,
I'll retire as a captain and that's what he did.
And then he retired as president,
great state.
So it worked out pretty well.
But that was his heart.
It was never about him.
Do you feel it's a well,
and that's,
let me tell you how tough that is to live up to.
Yeah.
I mean,
when you go by car iconic parents,
well that's exactly what I was gonna ask you that for you right now.
It's like you have your mission,
which is the next part of his mission in a way.
And I've been up to the,
to the library and in Simeon.
It's incredible.
I was at the,
uh,
the first Democrat debate there,
two,
two and a half years ago or so in this incredible building and just wonderful.
What else are you guys doing to keep these ideas alive?
Because that's really what will,
I mean the library,
the library does what they do and having the people come up there,
the debate that they have there,
they have guests up there on a regular,
uh,
Gary's,
Denise is going to be up there pretty soon.
Um,
and then I work with the young America's foundation at the Reagan ranch center
in Santa Barbara and the Reagan ranch where they bring high school kids from all
over the country come in,
they bring in speakers to speak there at the ranch center.
Uh,
they have lunches on Friday with speakers.
they bring in college kids from all over the country,
uh,
to be able to come in and go up and walk in the footsteps of Ronald Reagan and
see the ranch.
I mean,
people go up there and think they're going to see this great mansion.
His,
his,
his ranch house would probably fit in your studio.
I mean,
it just really,
it's a ranch house.
You don't go in there and see pictures of him with famous people.
You go in there and see paintings of horses.
It's a very good chance.
That's what it is.
And that's where he loved to be in [inaudible].
When you walk in the door of the ranch house,
you'll see a,
uh,
a,
a big,
uh,
a magazine,
from Montgomery Ward.
Uh,
and the reason he has that there,
his first job he ever tried to get was with Montgomery Ward and Iowa.
He turned him down and that's how he got into radio.
He turned him down for Montgomery Ward job.
You'll never make a kid goes over to who are WOC radio.
Yeah.
Ends up getting a job as a sports caster.
WSC and Louise,
where I look,
he never let someone else,
my wife told me this and my dad lived it and greatest thing that Colleen ever
told me,
don't let somebody else's attitude determine your attitude for the remainder of
the day.
And,
and my dad lived it and until I started to learn to live that I was a train
wreck.
So the ideas,
the ideas that he believed in the corners though,
things you've talked about here,
about,
about freedom and that he's,
he basically saved capitalism and saved the west and all of these things.
When,
when you see these days that there's this idea out there that socialism is cool
for young people or you,
you hear this now,
I mean,
I see you on Twitter,
you talk about this stuff.
Um,
scary.
It is scary.
Yeah.
Because our education system scary.
When you think can think about the thinking about state cal from born and raised
him,
people don't know.
They used to be number one in education is now 46th in education.
I mean we're not educating our kids who we become politically correct to the
education system.
Uh,
I remember when I went to Arizona State,
which would disallow me from ever running for Supreme Court justice.
Um,
because we're on social probation,
Arizona state,
everybody's on social probation.
We earned it the old fashioned way.
But you know,
when I went to school,
you know,
we're heard from many different philosophers,
different and different beliefs.
You heard them all and you know,
every week you said,
that sounds really good.
I think I'll be that this week,
weekend,
the next week or another.
But you,
you,
you learn things.
You had the breadth of knowledge.
Yeah,
you did.
Today it's,
it's completely different when you have schools who,
who if you walk into some schools and you have a,
uh,
Reagan hat,
yeah.
You know,
they get upset with you.
Or if you're so polarized,
nobody's conversing.
Nobody's talking,
nobody's sitting down.
Just let's have a conversation.
Let's find things that we agree on it.
It's always your,
you go to dinner,
you're afraid of,
there's somebody sitting next to you afraid of saying anything for,
for these people on this side of that stuff may get upset with what you're
saying and start yelling and screaming at you and that sad.
Or you have husbands or wives sitting down won't talk to each other.
[inaudible]
and it never used to be like that.
We used to be able to communicate and just sit down and talk.
I remember my dad saying to me one day,
his dad told him,
he said,
you know when the government starts paying and not to not to work,
why work?
His Dad taught him that.
My Dad taught me that,
you know,
you try to teach your kids that,
but now you try to teach them and everybody's got their,
like their,
their handout.
It's really interesting.
We support a little school in the middle of a slum,
not the foundation.
Clay and I know of a slum in India,
in Africa,
in Nairobi,
800,000 the slum school in the middle of it,
there were uniforms.
They teach them English.
They sing and they're smiling and they tell you is you're going through this
slum.
They say if you see somebody with their handout,
please don't put anything in it.
Why?
Because will keep them in the slum.
You want to help the people,
the slum,
give them educational material.
Education's the only way out of this slump.
And I'm thinking to myself,
why do they get it?
Why do they understand it in a slum of 800,000 in the middle of Nairobi?
And if I talk about it here,
I'm ridiculed.
How can you do that?
How can you say that?
Yeah.
Maybe we've become fat on some of the success.
That's because of a guy like your dad,
you know,
and it's uh,
it really,
it really is sad to,
to,
to look at.
I love traveling around the world.
You travel around the world and there's too many people here talking what they
think they know and they don't know anything cause they never been across their
own border,
but they know more than you do.
Don't you find that amazing yourself?
You'd go like,
really,
I've been,
you know,
you go,
I've been there.
How do you know that?
Yeah,
we'll all the time now you hear all the,
all the progressive,
they,
well we should just be more like Sweden.
Sweden's a tiny socialist country.
That's basically a homogenous until the last couple of years where no longer is
and now they have all sorts of problems and it's like,
have you guys been there?
Have you seen what's going on?
And they'd never been there,
but I know more about than you do.
You just didn't see it when you were there,
you know,
you didn't understand it called [inaudible].
Okay.
And that,
and so you do,
you find yourself,
unfortunately in a world today where people are afraid of dialogue,
they don't want to dialogue and,
and find that commonality like my father and tip O'Neill had to find a common
ground to give you the largest tax break in American history and you just had to
find it,
whatever it was.
And there's the people that elected Ronald Reagan,
you're talking about the Reagan Democrats didn't necessarily agree with him,
but they liked it.
They liked it.
And because they liked him,
they supported him and,
and,
and voted for him.
And you know,
it's getting to a point,
you know,
I want to see us be likable again.
Yeah.
All right.
So I don't want to end on that note.
So let's end on,
if your dad was here,
what would he be telling us in this,
in this strange polarizing time they were talking about right now.
Grow Up.
Just grow up.
I mean,
really just hear,
like you said,
there they go again.
Grow up and find a way to work together.
Uh,
that's,
that's what he's saying.
Fees very short and very sweet.
Grow Up.
You do a pretty good impression of your day,
by the way.
I only heard it for a second there,
but you know,
we had lunch while you're busting it out.
I did it on my radio show one time to interview with my dad doing both sides and
the office called me and they said,
how'd you get your dad on the air?
I said,
what are you talking about yesterday?
What are you talking about?
ABC,
NBC,
all these people call and there's a blackout on your dad because of Alzheimer's.
How'd you get him on the air?
All of a sudden I realized,
oh my God,
wow.
I said,
well,
I called and he answered the phone when he's not supposed to use on the phone.
I said,
well,
somebody should tell him.
And they said,
well,
Nancy supposed to answer the phone.
I said,
well,
that's not my problem.
I call,
he picked up the phone and say,
well,
you can't have them on the,
on your show anymore.
And as well,
why don't you let me ask my dad.
I said,
Dad,
do you want to be in my show again and well,
yes I do.
And also the office goes,
oh my God,
I see a volume full ABC,
NBC and CBS and my Dad's office.
I'm doing pretty good.
I'm going to tell the people to go to Reagan Legacy foundation.org.
But would you prefer to do that as your dad?
Uh,
well yes.
If you could go to Reagan's legacy foundation.org or walkway to victory.com and
really help help remember those who truly did save the world,
uh,
back in,
back in the day in,
in France.
And this is the way you can do it.
And as I said,
if you don't know someone who served,
then you can donate to the foundation.
And we have plenty of people and names that we'll put a name on a brick and put
it out there.
And what we do is we'll send you a video.
We have a 50 minute video that we did,
heroes of World War II that we give this people who purchase a brick and you'll
get a photo of the,
uh,
of the brick in the ground there at Saint Mary Glee's,
Normandy,
France.
And when you visit normally go to Saint Mary Gullies and look at the look at the
walkway to,
to freedom block walkway delivery of the walkway and,
and see the name of the person that you bought.
If you put a name on a brick,
W it's been a pleasure chatting with you.
And I sent to your dad's legacy is in good hands and I will tell them where to
go,
but I'm not going to do the impression you guys go to Reagan Legacy
foundation.org.